all right let's use really got soul
[Music]
you're gonna get back to talking about
the television output of a mr. Joss
Whedon got to get back to angel and this
time I'm gonna give my top ten
characters from angel if you're
wondering why I'm doing angel before
Buffy it's because I have sort of extra
plans for what I'm doing on the top 10
of Buffy so that'll be later it's just
taking me a little longer to get that
worked out so let's do angel top 10
characters I really like angel a lot I
think it had a terrific cast of actors
in really good characters really
well-written I'll just get right into
this so number 10 Doyle Doyle is a
character who honestly if he had been on
the show longer would have had a shot at
a higher spot yet at the same time the
amount of time he was there and the way
he went out was really good it really
worked it really fit it was appropriate
and he was it was really something to
see him go from the coward who just gets
the messages and sends angel off to take
care of everything to the guy willing to
lay down his life to help people like
himself something he never would have
done before and it was it was a good
thing to see and it did feel earned it
did feel built up to overtime plus he
was really funny
the actor was somebody who we lost too
early and and quite tragically
unfortunately but he was he was really
good he was really lovable and it was a
shame to lose him but at the same time
it it was a good send-off so number nine
yep escape god I love this guy the first
time I saw he's just saying hey my name
is skip
I can deal it here now I commute it's
not too bad yeah I love the whole thing
of a demon with a day job and lighting
like not like a day job like you or I
have like doing the kinds of things you
know we see angels and demons doing all
the times and these kinds of shows you
know which is guarding this thing you
know protecting the prophecy you know
this kind of nonsense but it's his job
he does and I did like that they brought
him back I didn't I don't love what
happened with him come season 4 it's not
awful as far as those sorts of turns go
with the characters it's not the worst
one but unfortunately my issue with it
is more that he feeds into thee and
we've been planning this for from the
beginning and it's like no don't buy
that that like I I never buy that and so
the fact that he feeds into that
unfortunately plays against it a little
bit knocks him down because he he easily
could have been a couple of spots higher
but man god he's fun and the design is
insane and ridiculous and I love the
contrast so number eight gun gun had to
grow on me initially he just felt I
don't know it felt like I wasn't sure
why he was there he was you know he was
the street you know scrappy kind of
tough guy and I'm like I mean I I get it
I suppose strictly speaking it's not a
niche being filled by the show otherwise
but is it a niche the show needs but he
grew on me a lot over time in many ways
because he grew as a character he did
grow above and beyond what we started in
being and what we started seeing him as
and more to the point his story
over the course of the show is very much
about him growing and changing and so
that wasn't just something that happened
that was an integral part of of him as a
character and ultimately sort of going
in some not-so-great directions when we
get to season five but also being able
to pull that off in a way that felt
organic and natural not forced not like
the awkward he'll turn like with
something like what happened with skip
but it was a completely understandable
series of choices that he made that led
to some bad stuff and his his journey
his relationships him like him and Fred
being together I didn't love but I like
better than Wesley forever being
together because that seemed just so
frigging obvious but it was it was it
was nice and he he grew on me over time
I went from being like he's fine to now
I like him so next up from there I
mentioned her already number seven Fred
another character much like Gunn who had
to grow on me I think because she sort
of filled a dual cliche initially you
know the the girl who's been you know
sort of stuck somewhere else for you
know the character who's been stuck
somewhere else for a while which is not
an uncommon thing to get in these high
fantasy or high-concept sci-fi kind of
shows and then in addition to that she
is the token
scientific mathematical genius which
again I was like do we do we need that I
mean we've got Wesley as the law Rexburg
do we need a stud do we need an
all-purpose science person character on
top of that so much like Gunn I was
skeptical of her at first but she's
really endearing and she's really
lovable and I think a lot of that comes
down to the performance I think the the
actress was really great at getting me
to love her and getting me to see her as
more than the character traits and
tropes that she fit into when she was
first introduced so next up number six
I've got to give a spot to a villain
Holtz his Holtz
kind of the wrote one-dimensional
villain out for revenge yes but he's
really good execution of that I think I
think the point at which I came to love
Holtz as a character was when he there's
the episode where Darla dies and Connor
is born it happens in the alley while
they're trying to escape for amendment
the whole sees this happen and he lets
angel take Connor and leave the alley
and you know he's got his sort of weird
genie friend guy being like Oh like what
did you do that why did you let him go
and you know you'd think having seen
enough of these kinds of things you
think that by seeing angel with a baby
he suddenly saw Humanity in this person
he previously thought of as a monster
but then he responds and you realized no
he sees a way to torture angel in a way
he never could before because now angel
is something that he cares about more
than himself and sort of that sinking in
and him jumping into that Hell dimension
with a baby in his arms and then you
know coming back and arranging for his
death in such a way as to ensure that
Connor would hate angel man this guy no
half measures and there were but and yet
at the same time the the way that he's
written and performed there are moments
where you think oh there's our
redemption moment no no redemption he
had oh wow he's worse than we thought
and it's that's not easy to pull off
because usually we either come to expect
well yeah we knew he was that bad this
isn't surprising or you know oh well
they've redeemed him there you go and
this rides the middle line and you know
it can trick you and that's that's not a
small feat so yeah I do like Holtz a lot
alright
top 5 number 5 Cordelia chase I'm glad
she got to be on this show
and got to have more depth than she had
on Buffy Cordelia was not I'd certainly
bought the end of the third season was
not as shallow a character as she
certainly wasn't my first season Buffy
she did game depth over time but she was
always still the pretty mean girl that's
who she was she was you know over time a
kind of slightly deeper version of that
but you know coming to LA she got the
wake-up call that I think a lot of you
know people who have it easy in high
school tend to get which is that yeah
you were hot stuff in your town but
you're in a whole new playground now and
you ain't nothing and I think she was a
good character too to have that
experience with because you obviously
couldn't do it with angel he's too old
he's been through too much there's not
really much you can put him through in
modern-day Los Angeles that is gonna
measure up to what he's already suffered
through I mean they would over time the
show puts it through the ringer but I
mean in terms of that kind of adjusting
to being in a new place in a new setting
so she was a really good character to
embody that element of the show
especially early on and then as her
character takes on more and she starts
to get the visions and all those things
I really enjoyed her character growth
that's something I've mentioned before a
little get mentioned again with other
characters her initial departure from
the show isn't great and that's me even
setting aside the circumstances or at
least as I understand them for what was
happening behind the scenes but just can
just containing it to the show it's not
great like she's a hero she's an angel
she's back she's a villain she's in a
coma but in the hundredth episode
bringing her back and giving her
character a proper send-off and proper
closure that was that was good and that
did that did a lot because if that had
never happened if that last appearance
in season 5 had not ever
happened that she would not be this high
on the list but that that did a lot to
sort of claw back some of the goodwill
lost with what happened with her in
season four so moving up the list number
four the man himself
angel angel is like so many leading
characters and these kinds of shows is
very tricky because you have to have
somebody good enough that you can get
behind them and be rooting for them but
someone with enough of an edge and
enough predictability where they're not
just the straight man and he could have
easily been that it's got a big enough
ensemble cast that he could have been
that and he could have just brooded his
way through the whole show and just been
like a Batman knockoff but he isn't and
it's because of certain twists that
they're able to do with his character as
time goes on so like getting the flash
back to the hotel and realizing that
even after getting his soul back he is
he was still at least in the not that
distant past for him at least as far as
his life time goes was still capable of
doing some pretty awful stuff or you
know in season three one when there's
Connor I know a lot of people hate
Connor as a character but I will stand
by the decision to give angel a son what
it brought out of him as a character was
really well done we did get to have him
as Angelus for a little while which is
always fun and and he got really good at
doing that and especially season five
you see that ruthlessness that you know
has been established across the season
up to that point that never fully left
him even when he got his soul back you
see that being applied to a mission to
take down the senior partners and I've
talked already about how much I loved
that last episode and he is a he is a
fairly but I mean I loved almost
everything about that last episode but
he is a pretty big part of it
plus he's a softy who likes Barry
Manilow it's it's an odd mix but it
works so number three
Spyke this should have been such a
gimmick total and complete utter gimmick
bringing spike on especially after he
died he died a sacrificial heroic death
on Buffy like this this should have been
awful bring him back but it works it
works for two reasons the first is they
have consequences and they have you know
actual weight and gravitas to the fact
that he came back from the dead which is
similar what they did with Buffy herself
on that show you know it's not just back
to him the dead everything's fine no
he's a ghost for a while
he's slipping into hell and you know
that so that gives weight to his return
that helps and then his dynamic with
angel and how much they cannot stand
each other souls know Souls doesn't
matter these guys hate each other but
they're also on the same side now and
it's it's really fun watching them
paying off each other and then every now
and then having those quiet bonding
moments as the two of them realized that
they possibly have more in common with
each other than anyone else on the
planet and they just have their little
moments of connection and I tend to
think of the hole in the world episode 4
that when they realize they're not gonna
be able to save Fred I think the weight
of that hits them both individually but
hits those two collectively because
they're in each other's presence all the
better and spike despite it you know
again should have been such a gimmick
great addition to the show now before I
get into the top 2 I have a character
who I feel like I need to acknowledge
why he did not make the top 10 because
otherwise people are gonna ask and
that's Lorne I don't dislike Loren I do
like Lauren but Lauren is also for me
the epitome of a supporting character he
is a character who has a great chemistry
and rapport with other characters he
does you know fun and interesting things
but anytime they put the spotlight on
him he doesn't work nearly as well he is
the essence of a supporting character
and if the show had left it at that
he would be on this list he would have
at the very least he would have bumped
out Doyle but because the show
kept coming back and putting a spotlight
on him even into season five when they
should have known better by then it just
never worked he was a terrific side
character that they didn't always
utilize well but he was he was a fun
character very well performed he would
be he'd be the Honorable Mention number
11 but now let's get back into the list
proper number two Illyria
hahaha man
this really shows the acting prowess to
go from Fred to Illyria
night and day these characters like no
resemblance to each other at all
and she feels dangerous and that is
impressing given how small and mousy and
lovable as Fred this person that we've
seen is but now that she's possessed and
taken over by this ruthless angry
goddess she is legitimately scary and
intimidating and I love the look I love
her interactions I love that they even
managed to humanize her without actually
like sort of say pulling a full-on yya
on her and you know reducing her down to
human they still manage to humanize her
by showing her pain it realizing that
her followers who she expected to be you
know the army that she would leave
they're all dead and the world has
forgotten her and so just starting from
there and then going through her trying
to adapt and again not playing it for
comedy the way as much you know it's
always something like Anya was done
doing it with weight and never
forgetting that she is dangerous and the
bond between her and Wesley that forms
is really really good in the and when he
dies in season five that is one of my
favorite moments were basically where he
gives her permission to lie to him and
to make him think she's Fred
and if you've been keeping track of the
major characters you should maybe
realize that that means number one
Wesley wyndam-pryce
this guy's character arc especially if
you go back to Buffy and to be like to
be clear I'm not counting his appearance
I'm buff because he was basically
unchanged from there to when he showed
up in season why he was the exact same
guy but his arc like you look at Wesley
in either season 3 of Buffy or season 1
of this show and you look at season 5
especially the end of season 5 it is
such a wide gulf between where he
started where he ended up but if you
watch everything in between it all
tracks it makes perfect sense every step
of the way every decision that he makes
that turns him from this you know weak
Weasley book knowledgeable guy who
doesn't you doesn't really seem prepared
to get his hands dirty to somebody who
will kill who will betray his friends if
he feels it's necessary who is prepared
to shoot his father it tracks it follows
it flows and it is no small feat I don't
I it's slightly hyperbolic to make this
comparison but I do feel it's worth
making all the same it's not dissimilar
to the kind of transformation you see
for Walter White in Breaking Bad now
again I'm not saying it's quite on that
same level because obviously that entire
show was about just that character so it
that's gonna be a little deeper a little
richer a little better but that from
starting point to end point and watching
that transformation from beginning to
end watching Breaking Bad did remind me
at a few points about watching Wesley
because you can see the you you get a
sense watching him you can see the gears
turning you feel like you can walk
the thought processes that lead him to
the these decisions to do things like
take Connor to do things like hook up
with Lila to do things like you know
work with Illyria and stand his ground
Lee needs to and and you know for all
the things that he does I think it's one
of the best long-term arcs in television
I do and that's why Wesley it's my
number one character from angel but
who's yours doesn't have to be one of
mine
what are your top ten or just what's
your favorite or how wrong am i whatever
your thoughts are drop something down to
comments let's talk about it you know
all the stuff that you can do you don't
need me to tell you I will mention that
I do have a patreon there's a link for
that below plus you know all the usual
stuff so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]